you have for a change of scenery look
you think they got a senior living in
Bolivia
Charlie
how can we help you
Betty told me everything
about how she saw you two tasing each
other in the hot house
that's how you trick the nurses into
thinking that Ben was having a heart
attack
when he'd really been dead for hours
pretty clever
but you missed one detail
what might that be
Ben's heart monitor recording When
totally flat
after
you stunt at 2 23.
the time of the monkey
but the nurses tried to revive him with
a defibrillator if he'd really been
wearing his heart cuff monitor it would
have registered those shocks
hmm
I think that's some [__]
and all this for a [__] who sent
us to prison for 30 years you deserved
it then
and you deserve it now wax up your
shuffleboard pucks ladies
as soon as I tell them I knew a FBI
buddy about all this well
yeah man yeah going right back to
Bedford
so you haven't told him all of this yet
[__]
[Music]
[__] Millennials I'm a Casper you
[__] psycho and I draw the line at
fighting little old ladies
that's how we did it in Bedford [__]
oh
the [__] oh
[__] close
you help me you [__] hurt huh
[Music]
get the [__] poison yeah yeah
keep her hell down
[Music]
don't you [__] try it put it down put
it down down
[Music]
I think we broke her
sit down
oh
[__]
oh thank God [__] [__] stop right there
stop
what a [__] cop
all right
well Charlie kale
you have great instincts you ever think
about joining the FBI oh
not really about helping the man
although what did you guys ever get my
email about uh Casimir Kane
you guys meaning who FBI at fbi.gov I
don't even know if that's a thing but
the offer stands
if you ever get in a jam you have my
number
totals
hello
[Music]
[Applause]